thank you so much for coming out tonight
raise a glass and toast to All of You
Beautiful People
cheers Anna said there was a man
outside they follow me over the wood
Braven get away from the
window
you all
[Music]
right it's amazing he didn't catch the
man well I haven't been sick in years
you just got lost a minute ago no I
didn't get lost listen I apologize if I
made you feel uncomfortable the other
night it's fine it's not fine my uncle
talks about you a lot my dad and I were
maybe thinking you could care for him
during the day all you'd have to do is
be there and go on walks and
stuff why did you follow me home from
the party
or do you only remember when it's
convenient I don't
[Music]
remember you don't know what you're
doing you're not able to make rational
decisions right
now why did you leave things were just
getting
complicated what do you
mean why did you and mom stop talking
when your mother was your age I she was
out of control no was
me I'm early hard
[Music]
done hi welcome back the usual for you
oh yeah what's the usual
I don't know you no do you remember her
[Music]
no